i'll tell everybody right now i didn't
hit the target spoiler
you got coveted yeah they are testing me
every week the first week i test
positive
and i'm calling home every night on my
new phone to my wife
crying like a little baby the number one
question people ask me is what if you
lost everything what would you do i
don't have to tell anybody what i would
do now
i can show them you're going to see over
12 weeks
exactly what i do
okay believe nation i got a special
guest with with me here today
you know him uncle g gc grant cardone
in the house star of the new show
undercover billionaire season two
how you doing grant good buddy good to
see you good appreciate you uh you know
spending some time with me and um
you know i'm a big fan so i know you got
that red wall the red wall is going to
be all awards
right the red wall is going to be all
the all the youtube awards
it's happening i think i have one
you knocked one but listen we got we got
us we got to launch
grant cardone in spanish and grant
cardone in
in russian and we we got to get some
more channels
is that what you're doing yeah i got a
russian channel and a spanish channel
with 500 000 each and then um
niche stuff so you can help like the
grant cardone real estate channel the
grant cardone marketing channel and the
grant cardone
you know pat the billing channel all
that stuff
anyway i wanted to quickly ship before
we dive in somebody asked me on
instagram and i know you saw us wanna
share with the audience
somebody asked me on instagram what have
you learned from grant cardone
and i said what i love about grant
cardone is he's always driving for the
next
big scary thing he's a good guy too
oh dude that's awesome man that's
awesome a lot of people don't a good guy
but you do
you you uh you yeah grant is
a really good guy people don't see it
the grant doesn't show that side but
deep down he's actually really really
good guy
you saved me a couple times with
relationships and connections that's
been super helpful for me so
um yeah i'm always happy to spread the
message and give you love
talking about doing the next big scary
thing though you got this awesome show
coming up undercover billionaire
yeah it's a wild ride bro like like
january they came to me and said hey
could you we have you as somebody that
that might
do this they were talking to a couple
different people you know i think you
know a couple of them
yeah i didn't know the guy a guy named
angus came to me
he works with a company called uh
t-i-j-a-t-t
chat they're a production company out of
la and he's like
look man you're my first choice to do
this show a guy named glenn stearns did
it last year i didn't know who glenn was
glenn glenn ran a big
mortgage company back 20 years ago and
made a bunch of money
i've never even heard the show he said
undercover billionaire i said i think i
saw that show he's like no not
undercover boss undercover billionaire
he knew immediately i had it you know
disassociated he's like discovery had
this
did this show last year 2018 it was a
big hit
it was discovery's first hit in three or
four years that really got my attention
interested me was that they already had
a hit meaning
they had to go feed the dog you know
they you got to feed the beast dude
once uh once you've got shamu at sea
world
then the shampoo's got to be fed and
that sea world will take care of shamu
because shambo is going to sell tickets
so i'm like okay this is even better
it's the second season
they're already pot committed you know
i'm doing my businesses
so they're going to promote the hell out
of this show so i'm like
i'm totally interested i said look i'll
do the show and the guy's like you don't
even know what i want you to do
i said [ __ ] man what's it called
undercover billionaires it sounds good
i said the only thing i need to tell i
need to tell you guys
you can't call me a billionaire if i'm
not a billionaire and he's like bro
we're not changing the name of the show
just because you ain't a billionaire yet
he's like you know what everything i see
online
you know like you've done billions of
dollars real estate transactions i'm
like yeah that's true he's like
good enough do you want to do the show
and he's like before you say yes you
should go watch
last year i'm like dude i don't need to
watch it he's like please go watch it
so this was january you know this is the
year
2020 is going to be the best year of
mankind this is all pre-coveted there
hadn't been a pandemic yet you know the
country hadn't got shut down
so i go watch the first three minutes of
this show
and i see the promo piece they do do on
this guy
glenn stern's billionaire blah blah blah
mortgage business he's getting off of
his jet getting on a helicopter
after his shot i'm like i'm doing this
show the first two minutes gonna make me
look good
as the show goes on they drop this guy
off in a city dude and they
they they take away his credit cards his
money his driver's license
he can't use his name can't use his
phone
and i'm like whoa and it got real scary
so i called my wife i said hey i think i
want to do this show
they want me to do it i know they're
going to pour some money behind their
promotion
and um what do you think
you know and she's like well how long
will you be going i said i'll be going
three months
but i'll try to get you guys out there i
was so naive about the whole thing i
thought
i was gonna be able to bring my family
out and do this
so uh we started shooting in march dude
it was the worst
the worst and best experience in my
entire lifetime
and i would never do it again by the way
why the worst and why the best
so it was the worst experience because
and this is all before cobit okay it was
the worst experience because
i just completely underestimated and
forgot what it's like not to have
anything
i completely had lost touch with
what people go through every day you
know
i had 100 bucks i couldn't use my name
one thing i learned was like some of the
things that we take for granted
and as soon as i say that everybody's
like oh yeah we take so much for granted
like our health
and food and water and shelter i'm not
even talking about that dude i'm talking
about your name
every time i went up to somebody i had
to use a different name
and which which immediately put me at
uncertainty
and into a life i mean the ability just
to tell the truth to people every day
is uh you know we take it for granted
like
like not not to mention water i had no
water i had no
no shelter it was 15 degrees outside i
had no place to sleep
i knew no one uh
couldn't use my name couldn't use any of
my past success
couldn't couldn't even use my past
failures
when communicating uh my authenticity
and transparency the things that i
really rely on or are
to you know that i that i've figured out
how to tell the truth to people
good bad or indifferent you know i am
who i am all the time and i couldn't be
me so that was the
hard part being away from my family was
extremely difficult
they give you a hundred bucks they give
you did they give you a truck or car or
something
yeah you know it's an all beat up truck
dude that can't be worth more than
you know if it's worth two grand i'm
shocked so they give you a truck 100
bucks
you can't use your name and in 90 days
you have to build a million dollar
evaluation business that's that's the
thing
i bet a million dollars that if i come
up short if i come up one penny short on
a million dollars i got to throw a
million dollars in
so if you don't make the million you got
to put in a million
if the there's going to be a evaluation
an evaluator come in at the end of the
at the end of the last show
if vegas was going to put odds on you
getting the million dollar evaluation
what do you what do you think the odds
should be
does gc hit the million dollars in many
days that's a great question
by the way no that's a that's an ask um
i don't think the odds would be maybe
you're obviously you know the results so
so we can't you know we can't share the
results before the show comes out but
what do you think the odds would be well
i'll tell you i'll tell everybody right
now
i did i didn't hit the target you didn't
hit the target
spoiler so so in discovery by the way
they hate me saying this
yeah like like they hate it they're like
you signed an nda you said that
i said okay whatever dude i mean we're
gonna sue me
i don't think you're gonna assume so
glenn didn't glenn didn't hit the target
either the first guy
no glenn didn't hit the target and i do
it completely different than glenn i
learned a lot watching the show by the
way when i watched glenn
i was literally taking notes don't do
that don't do that don't do that okay do
that do that that worked this didn't
work that worked
and and so you know the other thing that
people are not going to know unless they
lets me do things like this dude i got
so
i got so lost in this thing
that i'm still ruined from it i'm i'm a
little
over the whole deal actually and it's
been
it's been you gotta remember we started
this in march before covet was even a
thing
and then as i was there in this city
cobit started showing up in the news
14 days into it i picked up my first
check on the second week
it was a substantial check too i had my
first momentum
like after 10 or 10 or 11 days
and they shut the whole thing down and
i'm like what
dude it's over it's over i'm saying what
do you mean it's over okay now i'm
calling home every night
on my new phone to my wife crying like a
little baby
i can't do this she she literally kept
kept me in the deal for the first two
weeks
i finally got my first score i called
her i said dude i just got to score
this is going to work i'm going to be a
star people are going to love me
right and then that this same day they
woke up
the discovery came up to me and said
it's over i said what do you mean it's
over
we've got to pull the plug we can't
shoot covet the country's going to get
shut down
covet's going rampant we can't do this
anymore i'm like
dude i'm done i'm doing this thing
they're like you can do it if you want
to
we're out of here wow
so you where are you going to stay today
and just keep
there's not going to be any cameras so
you're not going to document it won't be
on the show it won't matter we'll call
you back in a couple of months when we
can come back
maybe we can come back in two weeks so i
had to go home
covet hit 40 will be unemployed
big economic contraction since the great
depression
and and then they call me two months
later you want to do it again
my hair was just starting to grow back
and i'm like dude i don't want to do
that again that was the worst experience
of my life
because what happened is i got into it
so big time like
i got so in this role of being broke and
having nothing and having to make it and
i literally forgot that in my meeting
for me was grant cardone
like like it's a bizarre kind of weird
phenomenon that
that kind of took over
because i really took on this whole the
whole idea that hey dude like there's a
lot of people every day in america
and in canada and around the world that
don't have anything
and they don't know where their next
paycheck is going to come from their
next meal is going to come from
i didn't know that i didn't know where i
was going to eat you mentioned you're
you're still messed up from it and
recovering
yeah how so now like you're back to the
real world
or maybe back to the grant cardone world
how are you still messed up from the
experience
dude because because every once in a
while i just like
i i you know my wife has to tell me hey
hey
everything's all right like it's all
right okay everything's all right like
something happened in this thing
uh i mean i'm reassessing my life like
what am i doing
what am i doing every day like i will
never ever
i literally lost 84 days with my kids
and and i'll never do that again that
will not happen
so um i would never do the deal again by
the way
okay i would never if they came back to
me and said do this show again we'll pay
you to do it i'd be like i'm not doing
that
i would tell i would tell people don't
do this thing
this thing is insane if you've ever lost
everything
and had to be without your family
without your friends
without your employees without the
people that support you every day
and you had to start over from nothing
it's not it's not something you want to
actually do
the stoic philosophers used to have a
practice of
every now and then basically being
homeless
and sleeping outside and and having
nothing just to remind themselves that
life isn't over if i were to lose
everything and it gave them more
courage to actually live the life that
they wanted
do you agree with that he's like no i
never want to go back and do that again
no i mean like like i understand that
they're doing that for you know it's
like fasting for a day
but you know you're going to eat
tomorrow
see the difference here is this wasn't a
day or two this was 90 days
it turned out to be five or six months
because when they stopped it and started
it again in the period of time they're
going to start again
i ca i've started some relationships in
the town that i was in
and i can't now talk to them and
and i'm coming back to my own problems
mid covid
you know i got seven little companies
right here we have 150 and lost an
entire division
during covid we lost people
uh so i'm managing am i going to go back
and do this thing with discovery oh i
got to manage my own
my own problems i got you know i got 8
000 apartments i got
you know the legal system's talking
about no evictions
renters don't have to pay freaking
world's coming apart
my own world that world i didn't know
whether i was going back staying here
like
all sudden i added something that that
the monk
the monk knows oh dude i'm going
the monastery you know on saturday
you know whether i was going back coming
back gonna finish this
not finish this didn't know if i
finished this year in 2020 because of
kovid i got sick
during the whole event you got coveted
yeah i got kobe when i
they called up and said you ready to go
it again i said dude i ain't doing that
deal again i'm not shaving my head again
i don't think it has to be different i
go back and they are testing me every
week the first week i test positive
wow everything about this thing was
insane me and the production crew
fought constantly like you you nobody's
gonna ever
see this like they hated me i hated them
like it was
terrible what did you fight over
everything like you're a maniac dude
like you gotta slow down we got
we got people here that need to follow
you people are being put at risk because
you i'm like yeah
that's the real world i said look follow
me
like we're shooting a tv show i said you
guys are shooting tv show
a million dollars on the line and my
my brand okay so if you need to get an
extra set of battery cameras more people
you need to have a a a shift that works
during the day and another ship that
works at night
do whatever you got to do i'm doing i am
not going to lose a million dollars
i'm going to build a million dollar
business i put during covid
otherwise i'm going to screw my brand up
okay so i either have to die
like i have to go down in flames trying
to pull this off
and look good if i hurt or i gotta
nexus one of the two but i can't look
back so
you guys and your cameras and your
batteries and your union
rules and policies uh and sorry you're
being put at risk so it was constant
like and i got
i have ideas about how to produce stuff
you know so
and they have ideas about how they want
to produce something you know how their
producers said hey grant you should
watch season one before you come out
just to know what you're getting into
i feel like they should uh had the crew
watch grant cardone videos before they
got into it so they know what they're
getting into
because telling grant to slow down is
probably not a good strategy
yeah exactly you know like one one of
the hardest things
uh doing it was just staying not
recognizable
so you know these these la people these
la production people they're a little
you know they're a little
little resentful tv people can be a
little resentful of successful people
and i have
you know i'm a very opinionated i'm like
guys why are we doing that
watch me follow me okay you can't
produce me
just come and they're like thing we
thought about was money
me a hundred dollars i didn't spend the
hundred dollars
and if you saw the first season i don't
know did you watch it i did yeah i
watched it
yeah so you know on the first day 100
becomes 88
day 2 64. day 3 41. they love that
picturesque oh he's going down
well i didn't spend 100 okay they're
like when are you going to spend that
hundred i said dude i ain't never gonna
spend a hundred we
never tapping that hundred
okay i don't need they're like you gotta
see it messed up
their way to cut or shoot a show and i'm
like guys
a hundred dollars can anybody i don't
even know why you guys gave me a hundred
why didn't you just take me to zero
right out of the
gate like i don't need a hundred dollars
i need to build
a business like
but when are you gonna spend a hundred i
said no the goal is not to spend the
hundred or say
the goals to build a million dollar
business
so i'm not going to manage 100 bucks
this is what my mom did her whole life
and why she never got ahead she she
basically saved money
and didn't want to spend and i'm like
look saving or spending is not the issue
here
creating is the issue follow me and then
i'm off to meeting people
trying to trying to produce some
business right and then they would ask
me things like
well what are you going to do you know
what are you going to do today about
starting a business i ain't got any
ideas
i don't even know where i'm going and
they're like
what are you going to do when you get
there i'm going to go meet people
but what kind of business you're gonna
create i don't know how would i know
that right now
like it would be like it would take me
like five weeks to figure out what kind
of business i'm gonna even do
and and that's not tv for them see they
they have a
they want to tell this story and the
story of the entrepreneur is not always
laid out so
succinctly
if you think about there's a lot of
people who watch your content
on a daily basis on youtube instagram
everywhere that you are
a lot of them are in that situation
right now where they're they're homeless
or they're trying to get started they
don't have a lot of money or
maybe they have 100 bucks their name
what piece
of typical grant cardone advice if you
look at kind of the themes that you
normally talk about what grant cardone
advice
is the best one the lifeblood of this
show
should be who's got my money
and you're going to see me i'm you know
i don't think i ever
turn there but this is literally who's
got my
million dollars there's one there's one
where i actually create this site i will
work for one minute
in my old truck so so look i'm going to
show people like
like literally you when you finish
watching gonna be like
and the one reason i'm really glad i did
this by the way is because
the number one question people ask me is
what if you lost everything what would
you do
i don't have to tell anybody what i
would do now i can show them
you're going to see over 12 weeks
exactly what i do
to go from zero to to building something
and how important was you mentioned
elena a while back
uh your wife how important was her
support in this whole thing i think a
lot of entrepreneurs getting started
don't have that how important was her
help
you know it was very very it was very uh
on one hand it was very important i felt
like she just kept saying
stay and after a while i'm like
dude do you know what i'm going through
here like
where is the empathy where is the
freaking caring about me
i need somebody to hold me right now i
was dying bro like
you're going to see me break down
multiple times in this thing
for real and and i'm laughing about it
now because i made it through but
but every time she would tell me just
hang in there
you know you can do it i'd be like i'd
hang up on her sometimes like
you don't even care about me right now
like it didn't feel like
yes it was that i would have stayed
but at the other hand dude it was it was
almost tough love it was like so
it was because she's disconnected from
my pain
she's in miami it's air-conditioned and
heat
it's beautiful she sees the she's got
the kids around her i have
nothing i mean i i'm wondering where am
i asleep tonight okay
uh is this actually gonna happen so
she's doing all her rah-rah
it really made me realize how i feel
feel listening to me when i'm like you
can do it don't quit
don't ever give up and i'm on my jet you
know and people like
dude dude you know because and i was in
my pain dude i was in my pain and my
discomfort and my
my vulnerability and in my in my mostly
in my uh
uncertainty the uncertainty was
like immense and she's over there you
could do it you can do it she's in her
cheerleader suit and i'm getting punched
in the face every time i turn around
and i'm fighting the crew and i i don't
think these people like me don't think
they want to be with me
so it was ugly bro like it was ugly so
on one hand
tell me to stay in there the only thing
that really helped me stay in the deal
every time she'd say do it for the
haters
every time you do that that's the one
that's your love language do it for the
haters that's my love language i'm like
okay
okay wrap that spot a little harder
you mentioned the the grant cardone
brand a couple times
what do you think this does for yeah and
looking at
the the the breakdowns and seeing you
at your lowest lows i think it actually
strengthens it i mean part of my secret
mission is to actually
show the world that grant cardone is a
good guy you know uh doesn't come up
as much but what do you think that does
to what do you think the show's going to
do for your brand showing that side of
things too
yeah i mean that that'll be that'll be
good i mean i you know
i i i hadn't actually thought about okay
does that help the brand i think it does
they're good they're gonna lay this show
out over 12 weeks two other women
actually take the challenge on
um into the country i didn't know that
when we shot it coveted shut the
shut it down so they were they were
gonna start shooting that at the end of
the year so they're gonna drop
all three of these in season two so i
think the fact that
there's two women uh
that come from different walks of life
that that's gonna open me up to a much
bigger audience that i wouldn't get
if it was just just me doing the show by
myself
um i think people seeing me struggle
will
will show people i'm human too you know
look when you don't have a place to eat
or piss
or a place to sleep you you start
meeting
you start meeting all the parts of that
guy people that are running in me today
see me
they see the life i'm living today you
don't see all the struggles i went
through in this show you actually see
the struggles i went through as a 25
year old
you know short of the drug addiction you
know you see
you see what i've been battling with for
35 years most people don't see
you don't see me struggling with money
today
but you see me struggling with money on
this show
what do you think is the greatest lesson
you learned from this whole experience
uh people man people are like the
lifeblood of
oh you know everybody's future you you
gotta you gotta figure out how to get
along with people
you know and
you can't do anything you can't do
anything big alone you've got to have
people
um i learned i learned a lot from this
doing this
be grateful for everything you have even
the problems because they can get worse
don't try to get me all re-stimulated
i'm just starting to get over this thing
you go where you want to go man i'm just
asking questions i love it i'm so pumped
for the show to come out
when i heard you were the guy i got
super pumped because i think of of all
the people that
that i know uh if you had to put like
horses in the race of who i would want
to see do it and who i would bet on
i'd put grant at the front of that list
one because you just you always throw
yourself in to the scary big things
and two just the the advice that kept
coming in my head was don't be afraid to
talk to strangers
like one of the pieces of content i keep
hearing you say is don't be afraid
to talk to strangers uh and how people
are so afraid to talk to strangers
and i know you love doing that and i
just thought you'd be perfectly armed to
be able to go off
and do this thing so i'm excited to see
i'm excited to see what happens
yeah and that's the other uh the you
know the other thing is
a little bit of the unfair advantage in
the in doing a show
um that most people probably when they
watch it won't pick up
is i'm four that that's one thing i
really did learn from this
options when i when i say success is my
duty that that was a really big thing
for me to
learn in my own life when you have
options you can sleep in when you don't
have options you can't sleep in
it's an unfair advantage in this show
the 90 days
actually creates an unfair advantage
uh the fact that it's being documented
is an unfair
advantage you know that
did i know it's going to be released on
tv is an unfair advantage the everyday
guy
your story is not going to be released
on tv you don't
have a 90 day deadline and you're not
going to pay a million dollars
it's not going to cost you a million
dollars supposedly if you lose
in my case the million-dollar bet the 90
days
and the fact that it was going to be pro
delivered
on discovery channel which is going to
be a million plus viewers a night
that's that gave me an unfair advantage
you know
that most people don't have
and when do you think you're going to
hit the billion
um you know i was talking to elena about
that yesterday last night i said you
know the kids are pretty guarant
pretty much guaranteed a slot i don't
know if i have time
but um maybe i do
i might who knows just gotta get i got
to keep making the right investments
and last question because i know our
time who would you nominate
to do the show who you think could do a
kick-ass job and get it done
yes look that's really a good question
um
i think about some of my friends that
that you know i've had on stages
and do deals with
i don't think i don't think most of them
would do the show i know a couple of
them
if this was an ice bucket challenge you
know and at the end you got to nominate
three people to do it
who would your three people be to say
who you think have a shot to be able to
do it
well i gotta almost not like you to say
this what do you think could do it who
could do it who do you think in our
circles could actually pull it off hit
the million
in 90 days and not quit uh just give me
some names i'll tell you whether they
could do it or not
okay let's let's start at the top who do
we got uh let's go youtube world so
uh gary vaynerchuk oh gary would be
interesting okay his problem would be
getting recognized
uh yeah gary would gary do this though
yeah whether they would do it or not how
far do you think it could eat kitty
gary gary's actually one of those guys i
think could make it garrett could do it
tony robbins uh couldn't do it and
wouldn't do it
couldn't do it because just too
recognized he couldn't no he couldn't do
it he couldn't
this this isn't about enough it's not
about emotional state i mean it's
it's it's not about rah-rah
state state it's about doo-doo when you
you don't have anything
kanye west kanye
uh i don't think
but i love fun would he would he make it
he wouldn't make it you don't think he
would make it
yeah he would make it he he he would be
cutting
you got to say okay how much help is he
going to get from the crew
tv just just between the two of us
is like reality tv some of it's not real
right some of it is and
helped and i mean if they give kanye
it will be fine but like
like they they couldn't give me much
help because
i had my own ideas about how i would do
this
and they they want they want to produce
tv i you know they're like where are you
going to sleep i said don't worry about
where i'm gonna sleep son but i
guarantee you i'm
i'm gonna find a place to sleep i was
looking at million dollar houses the
first three days i was in town
they're like what are you doing look at
a million dollar houses i got to know
where the rich people live
yeah i was in the most expensive house
in the city within
72 hours of getting to this little town
and was that part of your plan
to know where they're hanging out
where's my money at
yeah man go me yeah go who's got mama
poor people don't have my money
like if you don't have anything and you
want to up your game you got to go to
people have a better game than you got
i love it well the show is called
undercover billionaire
grant is the star of season two we'll
link it up down the description below
grant anywhere else you want people to
go
i left one person off the list dude you
you should take the challenge no
no no i would i would likely get
destroyed in that challenge i don't know
that that's uh that's
give me give me youtube world and i'm
gonna crush it put me in a in a truck
and have to do real estate deals that's
i might be calling you up for some
advice
i was i was talking to damon damon uh
damon john damon is like i got a json
man i would never do that show that was
that was a dumb ass decision for you to
do that
he's like give me c studio my shark tank
buddies i can do that he's like
you did was stupid i love shark tank
i'm a big fan that they could really put
entrepreneurship tv on the map
but i think i think what um
i think what this show does and just
watching season one
it really shows the kind of real world
of what what people have to deal with
and i think it's i think it's a great
series to continue and i'm super pumped
that
that you're doing it i think it's gonna
be a lot of life lessons i i love that
you're
getting out there more with that kind of
content because i think
your best when you're just off the cuff
on the go follow me around
let's do this and not the set one two
three by the numbers you're not the by
the numbers guy
i love that man yeah cool well
undercover building there season two
go watch it uh anywhere else you want to
send people to
grant well january 6 the show drops
january 6 but if your crew wants to
to watch behind the scenes we're going
to have a watch party
so you can go to grant cardone dot com
forward slash undercover grant
cardone.com forward slash undercover and
you can
we'll we'll invite you to to watch the
show the night it drops
and then when they go to commercial i'll
come in and tell
you what they didn't show you
discovery i'm sure the producers are
going to love you for that
now they're going to hate it but i i'll
tell you what i'll bet you a hundred
dollars on the side right now i get the
gun of this
i love it man well we'll link all that
up down in the description below
dude so pumped okay i'm glad you did it
uh thanks for taking the time today and
keep spending a message thank you
appreciate you brother i appreciate you
so much
okay much love thanks grant if you want
to see the last one-on-one interview i
did with grant cardone check it out
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe
and i'll see you there